percy et sur la prime d'activité si je
peux me permettre de rajouter un mot
vous savez que c'est la fusion de la
prime pour l'emploi et du rsa activité
vous allez avoir autour de vous des gens
qui vont venir qui sont perdants il
percevait la prime pour l'emploi que
vous aviez instauré et aujourd'hui avec
la prime d'activité ils ne sont plus
éligibles
ces huit cent mille personnes qui ne
sont plus éligibles à la prime pour
l'emploi
depuis que la prime d'activité est
arrivée la ministre des affaires
sociales a répondu à une question à
l'assemblée cette semaine elle a oublié
ce détail qui n'est pas un détail pour
toutes ces personnes
merci on continue sur les questions côté
verts votre nom et votre département
merci